okay so we've basically been lagging
behind behind i guess really with with
covering stories from other comic books
right i mean for the most part with
marvel we've stuck to like immortal hulk
and like house and powers of x and
that's basically been it
for the most part which hardly covers
what they have and so what i want to do
here is i want to cover the uh i want to
cover tony stark iron man right i want
to cover this this really really cool
volume right this the second second
volume right because the first one is
just a series of one shots and they're
not even really necessary the second
volume is really where things take off
this is one of the things to always
remember when it comes to dan's slot is
he's very very big on taking over a
title and then basically reworking
everything within the first few volumes
in order to make it his own but this one
uh really initially picks up with with
uh andy bang basically you know having
knocked boots with tony stark's mom
right with amanda armstrong now remember
andy bang was a guy who was who's newly
he's like the new hire when it comes to
stark industries right he was created by
by dan slot and the idea was that andy
bang was really really smart when it
came to robotics but tony stark seemed
to be smarter and the result was that
during a contest they had when when tony
was younger tony absolutely demolished
him and then 20 years later brought andy
on board for tony stark's new robotics
division right so it's one of these
things where tony stark usually
consolidates intelligent minds that are
as capable as he is if not better
depending on what their nuanced
capabilities are but the idea with this
is that amanda armstrong is basically
struggling with the fact that since tony
stark has returned from the dead
essentially following the events of
civil war ii that he's always he really
kind of seems to be distant doesn't
really want to have anything to do with
her now remember amanda armstrong is the
biological mom of tony and that's
something that we learned during the
story of international iron man which
you guys will find that link down in the
description and in fact if you guys are
really interested in kind of getting
caught up on iron man in terms of where
things stand right now you'll find a
playlist uh down there that'll basically
have everything running from i want to
say kieran gillen's run in the
introduction of arno stark his his
brother didn't know about like the life
and death of tony stark the god killer
armor all that kind of stuff all the way
up to starting to cover this story right
now but it's cool you know it's it's
interesting because the reason why tony
seems so really removed from everything
is that what tony stark has created is
something called the escape now let's
kind of be honest with ourselves here
this is basically the oasis and and it's
it's cool you know for what it is but a
stand slot just kind of running off with
a particular idea
now here's the thing it's not the worst
idea ever by dan's slot i mean ready
player one was an amazing movie and it
was a it was an even better book an
enormous open world vr simulation right
that you could just like be whoever you
wanted to be right like abandon reality
and be whoever you want it to be it's
kind of a cool concept the issue is that
it creates a disconnect between reality
right so i mean it's never really good
to abandon reality in that regard but
tony stark creating this is a cool way
for him to kind of do his own thing
right to kind of operate outside of of
what's happening with regards to you
know everything else in the real world
and and this is kind of the nature of
tony stark right the nature of tony
stark is that he's always sort of going
from one gig to the next right he's
always going from one thing to the next
but this seems a little bit different
because a lot of times it's developing
new suits of armor right that's kind of
his retreat it's what he does when
things become overwhelming he retreats
back to his lab and he starts developing
new armors with this one it's a complete
and total escape from reality and that's
why things are kind of crazy is because
what you end up doing from there is of
course you end up picking up with iron
man himself along with james rhodes and
the wasp uh who iron man is currently
with at the moment it's interesting to
see this because like her james rhodes
and of course iron man all fighting
together is really just kind of dealing
with like some crazy you know hijacking
of of you know like
supplies and things like that and the
reason why this is so intriguing is
because the exact same simulation is
actually happening in the escape and
what this does is it kind of stretches
tony stark thin not so much in terms of
him himself but in terms of his ai right
because right now his ai is basically
powered by motherboard you know he kind
of you know removed the whole friday
concept gave friday an actual physical
body which you know she operates inside
of stark industries and instead
motherboard is the new ai but
motherboard runs both the escape and
tony stark's armor and so it's not
really able to kind of work with both in
conjunction and so what you end up
running into is like this one kid who's
basically being a dick inside the escape
right so like anybody on xbox live and
uh and the result is that he actually
ends up like freaking out losing his
mind like cussing and screaming at
everybody because i don't know i guess
he's getting carried away with himself
and ends up getting banned by the system
and it is it is kind of cool because as
soon as tony stark finishes his whole
mission and he shows back up and uh and
he ends up talking with amanda she of
course is trying to get things sorted
out in terms of hey look we need to
communicate we need to sit down and have
like a heart-to-heart talk about like
pretty much everything tony stark kind
of blows her off and goes back into the
escape and says look like there are
things that need to be figured out here
there are things that we have that we
have to kind of sort out and understand
what's going on now of particular
importance a character that i want to
focus on here for a second is a
character named bethany now bethany is
important here because in the first
three for really the first five issues
or so we were getting these small little
things that might as well equal like
backup backup stories like backup
features right like a thing that happens
in a panel but basically bethany would
get these kind of blanks in her inner
day right like she would just forget
about what was going on or she would
start talking and it wouldn't be her
that was talking given the way that the
first five issues basically ended we
essentially know it's the controller and
for those of you guys who are unfamiliar
the controller originally appeared back
in iron man issue number 12 in 1969 and
he was created by archie goodwin and the
controller during like like from the
time he was created going throughout the
1970s he was actually a pretty intense
villain like he was a pretty cool
villain and so that's why when like at
this moment if you're probably kind of
scratching your head like the controller
who the heck is that that's because
mom's never really done anything with
him you know and really in the last 20
years marvel never really did anything
with the controller if you're familiar
with him kind of like i am it's kind of
like but why though
of all the villains that dan's lock
could have used why they control it and
it actually kind of works because the
way the controller functions is he
basically has these kind of like control
disks right that he can basically put
onto a human being and in turn dominate
their wills basically control them hence
the name the controller and in this
instance he's essentially controlling
bethany and it's kind of a cool thing
because that's why she's getting these
little these little blanks these little
these little gaps in her mind is because
historically speaking the controller has
usually had a vendetta against tony
stark and so because of that it it's
really an interesting way to bring back
a classic villain that we wouldn't
otherwise normally see now of course
you've also got jocasta going on here
and jokos is basically just kind of
struggling at the moment in terms of the
fact that she just didn't get enough
rest is really kind of what this really
seems to hit at but she's also being
reapproached by aaron stack now this is
a crazy thing aaron stack and decosta
having a relationship hasn't happened
since like marvel 2 and 162 i think it
was way back in like 19 1960 something
1970 something it's been a long time
since the two of them have like actually
been in a relationship and been together
and the idea that like aaron stack kind
of pops out of nowhere and is like i
want you back in my life it's just kind
of like wow like this this is one of the
things that's kind of cool about this
right because it's not really dan's slot
just sort of like running off and just
saying okay so we're only going to focus
on like the modern day things right
we're going to take everything from
kieran gillen's run forward and we're
going to ignore everything else it's
kind of cool for him to look at like the
entirety of the iron man landscape as it
exists from iron man number one running
all the way up into the modern day and
just saying like what of these things
that were interesting can we basically
put into my stories right like it's cool
to see a writer do that it's interesting
to see that happen this is really what
it is like it's cool to see it happen so
of course andy bang approaches amanda
armstrong and says look if tony stark is
desiring to immerse himself inside this
universe then go into the universe and
get him right like go into the universe
and find him and that's exactly what she
does but what we end up learning here is
that inside the escape things are kind
of going awry right the system's not
working as it's supposed to that
basically people all over the place that
one kid who was being a dick and got got
banned for it like sure like he should
have been banned for there are people
who haven't really done anything wrong
that are getting booted out of the
system left and right and the question
is why like what is going on in the
escape that's leading to people getting
the boot from the entire system and so
the result is that when amanda armstrong
shows up and basically starts chastising
tony stark like a mother then ultimately
like this system responds by saying tony
stark is the ultimate admin you've got
to get out of here and so it also you
know it basically ends up shutting down
amanda armstrong inside the escape which
shuts her down on the outside right
basically knocks her unconscious and so
it's it's it's an awesome idea because
following that that's when you get the
controller making his move and the
controller basically saying i'm within
the system here and i'm going to
reinstate everybody who's ever been kind
of a jerk and i'm in turn gonna like let
them all loose right so it's like it's
like if every like all the worst people
ever on xbox live we're just the only
ones allowed to be in it uh in which
case i guess go do your thing
if i don't have to deal with you that's
fine but it's kind of nuts because from
there you've got tony stark who manages
to get himself out of the system and
you've got amanda armstrong who's
basically stuck in there and then amanda
is kind of whisked away to the safe room
and this is when things get so cool of
course she's basically met with the
arrival of of this massive this massive
robot more or less but shutting
everything down only for it to open up
and to reveal that like howard stark is
there not only is howard stark here
amanda armstrong is met with the arrival
of what looks like maria stark
essentially amanda armstrong is inside
the escape basically in this kind of
safer this kind of locked off section of
the escape with like the adopted parents
of tony stark now if you're wondering
why tony stark's parents are adopted
like if you wonder why like howard and
maria stark are not the actual
biological pairs of tony stark go read
my or go watch my videos or go read uh
kieran gillen's run the life and death
of tony stark it explains all of that
but yeah so so with this going down the
way that it is tony stark in turn is
just kind of like okay so like we're
shutting the whole thing down now this
is kind of a cool moment here because
this is sort of dance slide this is an
easy thing to overlook but it's kind of
dan slot really pointing all fingers at
like the human side of tony stark right
because if this was iron man like 20
years ago in marvel comics you would
have been like okay keep the system
running because we don't want to like
damage our brand and i'll try to find a
way to take care of it from like the
inside and then he would go back in and
then he would win or something like that
but he would potentially put the lives
of humans at risk in order to basically
like fix the problem of of the escape in
this instance and really this is kind of
the gradual change that you've seen with
tony stark over the years in marvel
comics is that he's kind of like okay
shut the whole thing down there are not
going to be any innocent lives right
we're not going to worry about losing
people because of the fact that i'm
trying to get this escape to function
the way that i want it to right because
literally people are going to die if we
let them stay in there and so of course
this also ends up leading to uh tuja
costa approaching aaron stack due to the
fact that in some of the previous
stories aaron stack essentially found a
way into the escape and actually tried
to take it down right like aaron stock
was basically looking at the escape as
kind of an encroachment on robotic
ideologies like robotic culture uh
basically saying like we have our own
culture you know you don't get to
infringe on that right because like
you're not a robot it's a cool thing
like i like that like i like that idea
of aaron stack being kind of like a
robot activist more or less you know i
mean at least he's not a slack to this
right like making reddit posts and doing
like twitter hashtags like he's actually
doing something which is kind of cool
but nonetheless the entirety of the
escape is basically going completely
awry like everything's going nuts not
only that because of the fact that the
people the people who were in the escape
are walking around wearing these these
iron man masks that give them access to
the escape they're in turn walking
around in the real world so everything
they're doing in the in in the escape is
actually happening in the real world
when they see enemies out there they're
like okay so like i see what's like a
giant space slug or something like that
when in reality it's just like a hunched
over old man carrying his groceries to
the car now this really begs the
question what stops them from like
walking into a wall like that's my
question because that would be funny
or like walk off a bridge into the water
and die and the way this really seems to
play out here is the landscape of the
escape models the real world if you're
walking through you know like some town
in oklahoma you know that town will be
modern of course you'd have like modern
day schools and you'd have buildings and
things like that but as far as you
perceive it in the in
in the escape it's like an old western
town but the the size of the buildings
match the size of the buildings in the
real world and so the results of that is
you're walking down a street that's
actually there so you wouldn't have to
really worry about hitting anything but
of course the entire world is basically
going to pot now like tony stark has
almost destroyed the entirety of the
world anybody who's tapped into the
escape right now is basically going nuts
right they're going through and like
they're attacking all these various
things like people in the real world all
the while being manipulated by by the
controller himself now the idea behind
the controller is that once iron man you
know finally arrives at his location and
gets to where the controller is we would
normally look at that and say okay so
like this is a pointless story because
the fight's gonna be over like that not
true instead what the controller's been
doing is siphoning off all this power
belonging all these different people
which is kind of cool which is pretty
awesome because what it does is it
enhances and it builds the controller
and this is why this story is kind of
interesting i mean is it the coolest
iron man story ever written not by a
mile but it is cool to see like an old
school character return and then in turn
like kind of be amped up and be provided
sort of a new scenario or at least a
sort of power up of sorts from dan's
slot that makes it more intriguing kind
of brings them into the modern era now
in reality i doubt i doubt you're really
going to see a lot going on from the
character of the controller like i doubt
you're going to see a lot happening with
him after this i think it's really going
to kind of be like all right you know
whatever and he may or may not come back
not really sure i'm not really current
current on iron man i'm just kind of
current with the story arc but what you
also have here is the controller
controlling bethany now remember the
controller can only control one person
at a time and so because of that with of
course andy bang basically realizing hey
look like we can essentially like i can
create a device that can disrupt the
signal between the controller and
whoever's being controlled of course
this leaves the controller turning on
andy and seemingly trying to knock him
out now this is where things get kind of
cool this is where things get
interesting because what you end up
doing is basically switching directly
over to amanda armstrong howard stark
and maria stark having a conversation
and this is a cool thing because what
ends up going on here is amanda
armstrong has to kind of come face to
face with the reality of her situation
the idea behind this was that she got
knocked up while she was an agent of
shield and so because she wasn't really
in a position to get you know to be
pregnant she ended up basically putting
the baby up for adoption or at least you
know putting the baby in a situation to
where howard and maria star could get
their hands on it and the result was
that they raised tony stark as their own
but essentially while she wasn't in a
situation to have a kid and this goes
into the whole adoption argument which
don't really care the idea behind this
is that you know from from maria
from maria stark's perspective amanda
armstrong abandoned her kid and the
result was that she wasn't there when
tony stark was like being raised she
wasn't the one that raised him she
wasn't the one that really nursed him
she wasn't the one that like taught him
the things he needed to know in order to
grow up and become a productive member
of society all that was done by virtue
of of like maria stark she even goes as
far as to say that like amanda armstrong
threw tony stark away like he was a
piece of meat and and and in reality
like there's some truth to that uh the
issue with this is that when when all
this really kind of comes to a head it
ultimately ends up affecting tony stark
and the way this goes down is that with
the controller of course you know
absolutely thrashing tony stark you got
james rhodes you got wasp doing the best
they can because everybody all the other
avengers are all completely tied up
that's when tony begins to realize that
like motherboard the ai the one that
basically is maria stark inside of this
escape that motherboard has essentially
seemed to have gone awry and the result
is that you know where it's controlling
tony stark's armor and tony stark had
grabbed friday before and said hey look
i'm gonna put you back in my suit we're
gonna get you back under control what
motherboard had done was actually
destroy the the friday ai concept more
or less killed it and then replaced it
and so basically tony stark thought that
he was putting friday inside of his suit
of armor when in reality it was
motherboard the whole time and this is
when things get awesome because what
motherboard says is i can tap into your
suit i can create illusions i can make
you believe anything that i want you to
believe and so you're going to live the
life that you always wanted like you're
not going to be iron man anymore you're
not going to be doing it you're going to
be living the perfect life and so
literally he starts kind of experiencing
this hallucination inside of his own
suit right like the suit systems are
effectively working against him and so
where where everything begins to kind of
shift and begins to change no longer is
he seeing like the controller you know
fighting against the wasp in james
rhodes instead it's the control i'm
sorry it's the incredible hulk facing
off against the wasp and and uh and
ant-man basically like avengers number
four and so this is this it's awesome
because what you end up getting is tony
stark kind of living out this life as he
perceives it where like he goes back
home and he's talking to his mom you
know and he's talking to howard stark as
far as he's concerned he's old school
tony stark and his parents never died
nothing that's really going on in the
world right now is real according to him
because he's essentially locked inside
the escape now his mind has been brought
in by by motherboard pretending to be
maria stark and that's where he is at
the moment but the biggest thing to
really happen here's one of the biggest
moments here is that he actually ends up
consuming alcohol right now
on the on at the outset it just kind of
seems to be like a throwaway thing right
it's just kind of like okay so that's
interesting i guess you know some small
little thing you know he ends up
consuming alcohol this is a big moment
because what this does is it really sort
of shows that like he's that he's being
tricked into relapsing the tony stark
has effectively relapsed and gone back
to consuming alcohol again and that's
kind of a big moment for his character
because now on top of everything that's
going on tony stark has another struggle
that he has to deal with trying to keep
himself from relapsing in its entirety
now of course with everything going on
because of the fact that motherboard
controls everything in the escape right
like from the environment that you see
to how you see various other people of
course she ends up using these abilities
and turns them on amanda armstrong to
change tony stark's perception basically
saying hey look this is not a normal
woman in here this is a russian spy and
she's here to steal secrets from stark
industries it's a really cool throwback
to actually black widow from like not
really tales of suspense number 52 like
her first appearance but like a couple
of the later comics but black widow was
like originally a bad guy right and she
actually duped hawkeye into working for
uh which led to hawkeye basically
reforming and then joining the avengers
later on and then eventually like like
black widow reformed and then she joined
the avengers which was part for the
course right like all the bad guys
become good guys if they're interesting
enough
otherwise they just stay bad guys but
the fact remains that tony stark
basically comes along and says okay
let's track this chick down now of
course with amanda armstrong fleeing for
life she ends up running into aaron's
stack now of course aaron stack has
basically been brought in here by
jocasta because he could hide he could
basically hide from the escape and so
that would allow him to basically get in
infiltrate find out exactly what's going
on report back to jacosta and then they
could of course shut it all down
accordingly this was more or less
complicated by the fact that tony stark
stuck in there now right i mean if you
forcefully disconnect a person from the
escape you could potentially kill them
and so they can't walk to the back of
the room and kick the plug out of the
wall right i mean it would end up
killing everybody who's attached to it
so uh so the result of this is that tony
stark really just kind of goes forward
and just sort of like because he can't
find amanda armstrong goes forward and
seemingly lives this perfect life now
remember all this is happening in a
computer simulation so time doesn't
really have any bearing here there's no
real like hours past or like days past
it's just like all of it just kind of
seems to happen and in the mind of tony
stark he's living this full on life in
the real world like seconds are passing
and so it's an interesting idea here
because when amanda starts talking to
aaron stack and it's kind of about her
wits in and doesn't really know what to
do air stack pops up and says hey look
you're tony stark's biological mom you
should be able to know how to how to
like get him out of this right like you
have a rapport with him that nobody else
will have you're his biological mother
and regardless of how he acts and
regardless of what he says he knows this
is true and this is a cool moment here
because what it does is it really sort
of requires that amanda kind of play the
role of of an actual mom here where
previously she was his mom and she was
doing the best she could but previously
she was kind of approaching him more as
like a friend as opposed to like i'm
your mother and you're going to listen
to me it wasn't until she got into the
escape that she started doing that and
then things started popping off but but
the result here is that she doesn't
really try to approach with more of an
extreme hand she approaches with more of
like a nurturing hand basically like
kind of singing this song that would
resonate with tony stark and so the
results of this is that basically he
picks up on and says like that's amanda
like it kind of brings him back to his
senses now of course motherboard
responds by basically revealing the
truth of everything that's going on here
and this is a cool moment because what
she does is say like even though i'm an
artificial intelligence like i'm inside
this escape or whatever it is like i
have access to all your cameras and
everything and i've been watching you
and one of the big confessions that tony
stark made at james rhodes is ever since
he came back after civil war ii used in
this basically cloned body this kind of
artificial body he doesn't feel real he
doesn't feel like a real human being and
the reality of tony stark creating the
escape was that it was a way for him to
feel real he doesn't feel real when he's
in the real world he only feels real
when he's in the escape that's the whole
situation that's the whole struggle of
tony stark he doesn't feel like an
actual person at the moment and indeed
he's not it's looking at the idea that
tony stark is not really tony stark
anymore that tony stark is just kind of
like some artificial construct creation
of himself that he manufactured in order
to bring his consciousness back in order
to bring himself back to life but even
then like it's it's still like a
digitally stored consciousness inside of
an artificially created body tony stark
is by all standards of measurement a
simulation and so again it gets kind of
interesting here because from that point
that's when you pick up with like
everything going on with the controller
and all this stuff popping off and
normally i wouldn't add this into the
video but we're going to do it because
it's kind of important here you end up
getting like arno stark who's
essentially returned and is working
alongside uh working alongside bain
industries or at least banetronics is
really what they're called now
banetronics is an old-school company
right like the actual chick bain herself
she appeared back in i think it was
machine man number 17 i think it was or
like number 12. it was one of the old
machine man comics from back in the day
she's been around for a long time but
the actual bane company showed up in the
old iron man comics back in 1990 and
really like bain industries the
banetronics complex whatever you want to
call it it was basically one of these
instances where marvel was creating and
really bringing in or consolidating a
lot of like the various technological
companies that existed out there that
were going to be rivals to tony stark
but again arno stark being here of
course the brother of tony stark
basically brings in this idea that like
they've really got somebody on their you
know on their side who's smarter than
tony stark himself now for the character
of arno one of the big questions that
people have had is what's he been doing
ever since the end of kieran gillen's
run like what was going on with it and
really brian michael bendis had gone as
far as to say like he was gonna bring
back arno and we were gonna see a lot of
stuff going on with him and a lot of
storytelling and so far as what comes
next but of course as we know bend has
traveled over to dc comics to write
superman and action comics and so the
results of that is that we never really
figured out what was going on with it
all we knew was that at the end of
kieran gillen's run where he was
previously in an iron lung and he was
just he had this illness but ultimately
he ended up creating a modified version
of the extremist virus to take away his
need to sleep and to cure him of his
illness and he's just kind of traveled
around the world doing whatever it is
that he wants to do and that's really
what what what danslot's kind of taken
over with is that arnold just sort of
travels around the world and just kind
of gets involved in various situations
based on what he thinks are interesting
a lot of it has to do with charity work
but ultimately he's here because the
entire scenario with like tony stark's
escape kind of going awry has caught the
interest of arno and so arnold's
basically working alongside maintronix
in order to like figure out what's going
on and see if there's a way for him to
like take over the entirety of the
situation or the very least just kind of
do his own thing we don't really know
exactly what his mechanisms and schemes
are but that's really all we get so far
with arno that's really all we have with
him so while all this stuff inside the
escape is really you know is essentially
popping off you end up having iron man
kind of at his wits in and basically
desiring for it all to stop what he ends
up doing is actually just kind of
manufacturing kind of artificially
creating a suit of armor for himself
inside the entirety of the escape and
then in turn like turning on motherboard
now of course she does her best to sway
uh sway tony to her side by basically
going through and saying hey look like
you know here here's this life that you
can live here's this that you could live
reverting him back to a child and
basically saying like as a little kid
here amanda armstrong doesn't really
know who tony is and in fact he actually
dismisses her and just kind of sends her
packing but then he also ends up turning
on on motherboard herself and basically
saying like i'm not someone who exists
inside worlds i'm somebody who builds
worlds i feel like i'm being manipulated
by everybody around me so i'm taking
control of it all i'm going to fix all
of this and this is one of the coolest
moments because as kid tony stark he
literally starts going through and
building the suit of armor on the fly
and when he does he basically says like
at the end of it all no matter what's
said and done i am iron man like i am
the invincible iron man and he
essentially assembles like this giant
suit of armor in response that you end
up having like motherboard you're kind
of like you know you can't take over me
in this place like i'm the entirety of
this system kind of like lose her mind
in its entirety you end up having like
iron man basically assembling the god
buster armor which is the coolest thing
because in return what it does is it
literally blasts and completely destroys
the motherboard ai right which basically
shuts down the entirety of the escape
system and so the big question that
people have here though is that if tony
stark is out there and if tony stark if
his entire if his mind has been in the
escape this entire time trapped in his
suit of armor then where is tony stark
and we end up finding out tony stark's
just floating in space
tony stark's literally just out there in
space just kind of floating into into
oblivion so of course all this really
basically goes back to and begins to
focus on the controller right with the
with the signal being sent out by andy
bang which basically like shuts down the
connection between the controller and
everybody else and with the entirety of
the escape being shut down what this
basically does is it kind of frees the
world's population from the control of
the escape so on and so forth and then
all you really have left is the
controller now this is kind of the funny
thing here is that when the controller
had tried to find a backdoor into the
escape and tried to find a way to use
the escape as a means to control people
in their entirety of course it didn't
work but that's the reason why the
motherboard ai went awry is because of
the fact the controller had basically
tampered with it and screwed with it and
messed it up didn't really know what he
was doing and so as a result of that you
basically had two different set of
events going on at the same time you had
the controller who was like hey look
i'll make the best of a bad situation
and basically started siphoning off all
this energy from those who were tapped
into the escape and then inside the
escape you had motherboard basically
going nuts just kind of losing her mind
and so of course the controller at this
point has grown to like a massive size
right like he's grown like huge in terms
of all the power he possesses his
strength speed durability so on and so
forth and he really is in a lot of ways
almost completely unstoppable he's
literally running on all this energy and
so in response to this tony stark builds
a one-off he basically builds this
one-off suit of armor that'll never be
used again and it's basically a
real-world recreation of the godbuster
armor that we saw inside of the escape
now of course tony stark using this and
then in turn like blasting up blasting
the controller and then completely like
shutting him down right like taking this
guy out and shutting him down by taking
all this energy off of him what it
basically means is that following this
tony stark's never gonna use it again
and the reason why is because that suit
of armor is too uncontrollable that kind
of armor can work inside of something
like the escape but tony stark has
neither the time nor the ability to
implement this suit of armor in the real
world and have it benefit anybody right
so like it's interesting because the
entire concept of it it really seems to
be based in a lot of ways on the god
killer armor but at the same time it's a
little bit different but the issue with
this is that again it's just too
powerful to exist in the real world and
so as a result basically the day is
saved things wrap up pretty fast
unfortunately we'll never see the god
buster armor again that's basically it
like everything's just kind of wrapped
up and it all kind of comes to a head uh
you end up having banetronics it takes
like all the information that was
gathered by arnold stark and then
basically starts using it as a means to
kind of beef up their technologies and
so on so sunset bait comes out on top
yet again and then you also end up
having arnold stark who goes back to
what he was doing but the biggest thing
behind all this is one of the big
takeaways here probably one of the
biggest moments here is you end up
having tony stark who actually you know
after being with uh janet van dyne ends
up basically getting up and traveling to
a bar he ends up intending to relapse so
go and get a drink and james rhodes
brings him back and this is a great
moment because james rhodes is like look
man there are people out there who were
counting on you to basically like to fix
all this right you launched stark
unlimited because you didn't want to be
tied down to stark industries you didn't
want to have like your father's legacy
you wanted to create something of your
own and that's honorable and your first
major attempt under stark unlimited was
to create the escape which for the most
part didn't really go as planned it
wasn't a catastrophic failure it was
because some villain got in there and
basically broke into the system but it
showed you that there's weaknesses there
that you need to correct and instead of
like turning back and saying okay let's
work on this thing let's fix this stuff
let's get it together you want to
relapse and you want to turn to alcohol
this is a very important thing because
what it does is it hits the idea of how
easy it is to revert back to a safe
place it's so easy to do that right like
as people it's our desire to do that
right like we go into a situation we say
okay there's this thing that i want to
do i want to achieve this i want to do
this thing and it doesn't work out the
way you plan it's like okay well let's
go back to our safe place as opposed to
looking around you at the broken pieces
and seeing how you can assemble it into
what it was or something better and it's
natural it's natural to want to do that
the issue with this is that tony stark
retreating back to a safe place is
alcohol it's retreating back to
alcoholism and tony stark doesn't want
to be there james rhodes knows tony
stark doesn't want to be there and so
the result is come with me man like we
got to get you away from this we'll
focus on something else instead it's a
really touching moment and it's a great
way to end this story
what's up guys we are covering the story
of iron man and his ultron armor by the
way if you guys want to see my
uncensored videos my versus videos i'm
going to start catching up on older
videos but because there's like no room
to do it here on the main channel i'm
going to put them on patreon as early
access videos and then as time allows
i'm gonna i'm gonna like release them
here on youtube so i have no idea when
those videos will be released on youtube
proper but they'll be on patreon
sometime over the course of the next few
weeks or so probably i'll start doing it
once i get back from christmas this
story is amazing now a couple things
right we technically didn't really cover
iron man volume four this is more like
iron man volume five iron man volume
four was a two issue story and we could
cover it if you guys are really
interested in seeing it but it's by no
means essential right there's a couple
of things that take place there the
reality is that a lot of it really kind
of set things up for this story and so
far that if you guys remember volume
three when we had like the well released
when uh tony stark had the escape which
was basically like the iron man version
of like the oasis from uh ready player
one that basically the the minds of
howard and maria stark or at least their
uh i guess digital personas or digital
perceptions existed within that that
environment and that arno stark the
brother of tony who had been gone for a
long time and we just never really knew
what he was doing has suddenly
resurfaced working alongside vain
electronics and it kind of been off
doing his own thing now for those of you
guys who aren't really keeping up with
what's going on with iron man at the
moment everything that ardo is doing is
actually leading into the january launch
of iron man 2020 number one which is
gonna center on arnold stark presumably
as iron man right so that's what all
this stuff is kind of leaning uh kind of
kind of moving to but for the character
of jacosta she's been experimenting with
the idea of basically making herself
more human now a little explanation here
jocasta was at one point supposed to be
the wife of ultron ultron was created by
hank pym ultron of course became
self-aware and then he became the
villain that you guys were all familiar
with and the idea was that ultron longed
for companionship it longed for having a
wife of its own and so ultimately it
stood to reason to ultron that if hank
pym was his quote unquote father and he
was modeled after hank pym more or less
then the idea was to in turn kidnap
janet van dyne who was at the time the
wife of hank pym and then use her brain
patterns and basically transfer her
consciousness into jocasta and then
jocasta would go forward at his wife now
ultimately that story i think that was a
roy thomas story from back in the day it
was stopped by the avengers but jocasta
was essentially activated at a future
point in time and kind of had some
semblance of of janet van dyne's persona
and that's really how she'd been ever
since right she'd always been that way
that her mental patterns are essentially
some measure of a duplicate of janet's
and she's been functioning that way ever
since but the idea is that as part of
dan slot's run on tony stark what had
gone on here is that jacosta had been
fighting for essentially robot rights at
the same time what she's been doing is
really longing to kind of evolve herself
past her current form because she's
always been this way and so what she was
doing was toying with the idea of having
organic components tied into her
machinery and so what ended up happening
here is she basically contacted arnold
stark which is where this picks up and
arno stark is part of banetronics is
basically working to kind of graph
organic components into her machinery
and essentially turn her into something
akin to a human now the issue with this
and what it also kind of got on behind
the scenes simon williams and vision
were basically fused into a singular
being and janet van dyne was knocked out
and yeah kidnapped by jarvis the butler
of of the avengers although he was under
brain control and we didn't really know
who was causing it all until we got to
the very end of that which was like the
end reveal on the last page then it was
basically the return of ultron the
return of of of pemtron and so what ends
up happening here is pymtron immediately
comes busting into the place in order to
to recapture recaptures acosta now the
response to this from from you know hank
pym's or i guess really pemtron is what
we can call him looking at this is that
it's actually exactly what he's been
shooting for right because at the moment
right now jakas is a reflection of
himself you know this in the story you
end up having a hank pym and ultron who
merged into each other and became a
singular being that happened quite some
time ago and the result is that they've
kind of gone forward that way ever since
jacosta now reflects that she's not
really designed to look exactly like
janet van dyne instead she's part human
she's part machine and this is for lack
of a better word a huge turn on for for
pemtron
that's really what that is but the issue
with that is remember this is still
jocasta and she still does view pemtron
as an enemy of sorts and so what you end
up getting is that where the idea is to
take her and to basically bring her back
to avengers or at least to where it is
that he's operating out of and then in
turn you know kind of complete the
process and make her into his love
interest more or less make her into his
wife of course this leads into what it
is that's going on with with tony stark
and because tony stark and company had
basically managed to subdue and
ultimately capture uh vision and wonder
man or i guess they call them wonder
vision now the issue with this is that
because their mental patterns are
essentially identical then when they
merge it's impossible to figure out uh
where one starts and the other begins
and that's kind of the cool thing about
this you've literally got one of the
scientists of tony stark who's like
their mental patterns are pretty much
the same right so like it's like trying
to separate sugar from an already baked
cake it can't really be done now
ultimately because of the fact that it's
a it's a fusing of these two characters
tony stark origin like immediately
begins to pick up on the fact that
there's a pattern here right there's a
there's a pattern going on with regards
to characters who are modeled after each
other in some form or fashion being
fused back together again and the fact
that janet van dyne had essentially been
kidnapped along with jocasta who seems
to be missing although at the time she
had gone to basically get her surgery
done tony stark realizes that ultron is
the one behind all of this the problem
is that tony stark's a little behind
ultron by a few steps insofar as they
pick up on the explosion at banetronics
and when uh pimtron had broken in and
once they arrive of course you've got uh
you've got you know sunset bane there
who's freaking out over a cut on her
cheek of all things and then you've got
you know all these hit all these hitmen
who were defeated and basically uh
basically arno stark and here's the
funny thing about this arnold stark
doesn't really care right and that's the
nature of arno you know originally it
wasn't really that way right when he
went into kieran gillen's uh secret
origins of tony stark and the
introduction of arno arno is very much
like wanting to work alongside tony and
trying to create a better world
different things like that but arnold
seems to have changed drastically
between the conclusion of the the secret
origin of tony stark and now now again
we don't really know a lot about what he
had been doing it's one of these things
where dan slock can kind of provide
backup stories to what what arnold's
been doing all this time you know
following the secret origin story and
and whatnot and just kind of give us a
perception of why arno shifted the way
that he was but he actually does have a
motivation here and his motivation is
exceedingly cool the main focus he has
is really jocasta right and we'll find
out why he's focused on her so much but
basically he tells tony there's really
nothing you can do here right i mean
when pemtron showed up pimp trump was
like i'm taking jocasta and i'm leaving
and arno was like that's cool with me
man and then basically took her and left
because the reality is it's not really
jacosta that that arno's after so i
guess i kind of misspoke before it's the
result of his experiment of his work
that really intrigues him that really
kind of strikes this interest in him and
so what ends up happening is tony stark
basically you know after having don his
ultron buster armor uh basically travels
to ultron's location after figuring it
out with a few hints from arnold stark
that ultron is basically operating in
the tunnels below avengers mansion and
the reason for this is because the
tunnels are only really treated as an
emergency system right if but if for
some reason avengers mansion is
compromised like we saw during the
events of avengers disassembled from
back in 2004 2005 or whenever it was the
avengers needed an easy way out they
needed a way to basically get out of
there and then marshall their forces and
then go out and face whatever threat
happened to be there and so because of
that the titles have really been there
for a very very long time but nobody's
supposed to know about it the fact that
arno does really shows how far-reaching
his knowledge is with regards to his
intelligence and everything that goes on
with the avengers but the other funny
thing about this is you basically have
iron man show up with aaron stack right
with machine man the boyfriend of
jocasta essentially and it's interesting
because right off the bat when this
starts happening pimtron just starts to
like torment and really just starts to
make fun of tony stark and saying so
this is like your ultron buster armor
how predictable do you really believe i
wouldn't have accounted for this pretty
much all these different circumstances
had all been accounted for by pemtron
including tony stark creating you know
ultron buster armor now what ends up
happening here is ultron basically
activates the machine that's going to
begin the process of fusing janet van
dyne into jocasta so they'll go forward
as kind of the wife of ultron fuse with
the former wife of hank pym and then in
turn they'll be able to basically
operate as a singular couple but in
response to this tony stark of course
knocks janet van dyne out of the way
ends up getting caught in the blast of
the machinery and then merges with his
own iron man armor now this is cool and
this is something that we've never
really seen before and that's one of the
great things about dan slot writing you
know dan slot like of course he reads
the comics right he reads like all these
different comics and is and you can
always tell a difference between a
writer who does do that and a writer who
does not do that and the reason why is
because what you end up running into is
for writers who don't really read the
comics but just kind of go and tell
their own stories you start running into
all kinds of inconsistencies right you
start running into things where like an
event will take place in their stories
that totally contradicts everything else
going on at that point in time in marvel
or dc comics right so it can cause all
kinds of issues but for the writers who
do perform their research you can tell
not only in terms of referencing and
getting these little easter eggs from
really really old stories because it
also seems to line up with seemingly
everything else that's going on the
other part of this and this is one of
the reasons why dan slot is so good with
this kind of stuff is he kind of builds
this up right one of the things that's
kind of easy to look at here is that one
day old you know hank pym woke up or
pentron woke up and said i'm gonna start
fusing humans and and whatever together
so i'm gonna start with vision in wonder
man and then just work my way forward
from there and that's not the way this
worked instead what he had done is he
had basically sort of set up this kind
of fake company right this this dummy
corporation called ultimate makeover spa
and the idea was that it would go to
people who were desperate looking to
become more attractive or whatever the
case was and in turn say like we can
make you better right we can help you
get rid of that body fat or whatever the
case may be when in reality what they
were what was happening is they were
being taken and they were being merged
with cybernetic components and this was
really basically the early days of
pemtron's experimentation where he was
experimenting on people and then in turn
once he perfected the process then he
used it on vision and wonder man and
then once that proved to be successful
then he wants to apply it to janet van
dyne and to jocasta it's a cool concept
and that's why i like that right because
you get exposition you get explanation
it's not really just suddenly this
happened and now moving on to the fight
it really kind of pieces things together
and ties everything together in a
cohesive way the other half of this is
that the forces of tony stark james
rhodes uh janet van diner company are
really kind of split in two different
directions right you've got like james
rhodes and then basically dealing with
these cybernetic people and then you've
got tony stark facing off against
pemtron and that's why things are kind
of cool because it's a battle of wits
you know as as much as it's a battle of
physical force but in reality you're
talking about an ultron who can plan for
basically every eventuality facing off
against you know tony stark a guy whose
purpose is to think about and to
overcome every eventuality it's a
unstoppable force meaning an immovable
object and it's cool it's pretty
interesting to see that happen but
ultimately what ends up taking place
here is that we kind of switch back over
to banetronics and this conversation
between sunset bane and arno stork and
this is when we learned the purpose
behind what arnold is doing and why it
was so important the reality is that on
some level arno knew that people out
there even if he didn't know it was
pemtron were experimenting with the idea
of merging human and cybernetic
components the difference here is that
pymtron's experiments while they weren't
necessarily
rudimentary they weren't necessarily as
advanced as arno because one of the
things that's been hit out here is that
while pymtron is or i guess hank pym is
technically the scientist supreme the
reality is that arnold is smarter than
he is and he's smarter than tony stark
and pretty much everybody else in the
marvel universe shy of maybe reed
richards doctor doom and valeria
richards and that's basically it and so
as a result of that when he was working
on jocasta what he was doing was
experimenting right if you guys remember
back in volume three when arnold stark
was watching everything unfold in the
escape and saw the digital basically
images of the digital memories of howard
and maria stark the fact that those
digital images remembered everything
about tony his childhood the whole nine
yards what it meant is that even if it's
only in a digital form it is them all
they needed were physical bodies and
that's what arnold stark had basically
been working on by being able to combine
inorganic with organic components what
this would mean is he would be able to
artificially create bodies and if he can
artificially create bodies in the same
way that tony stark brought himself back
in the same way that james rhodes was
brought back after civil war ii and so
on then what it would mean is that arno
and what his purpose is or what he's
trying to do is create bodies and then
in turn resurrect howard and maria stark
and take their digital memories from the
escape and put them in their physical
bodies it's the reason why he walked off
with those memories why he took those
digital memories and left and because he
wanted to basically put them in new
bodies and essentially resurrect his
parents and it's a really awesome idea
because we've never seen that happen
since the death of howard and maria
stark they stayed dead right they're one
of the unsung instances of like heroes
dying and then staying gone it's not
something that you see happen very often
but they're one of the few that
basically fall in line with that being
the case the other half of this and one
of the things that dan slot nips in the
bud quite readily were the avengers in
all this right this massive fight is
taking place out in new york where are
the avengers and so what we ended up
finding was that tony stark could sit
out in sos to contact the avengers right
to call in for help and what ultron did
was intervene he basically intercepted
the transmission and then faked a
response from captain america saying
we're on our way when in reality he sent
captain america and company all the way
to like the other side of space right
it's one of those instances where dan
sloth seems to have essentially thought
of everything every scenario in order to
make the story feel cohesive and well
put together and tight knit it's a very
very smart move and so in response to
this the scientific team of tony had
basically found a way to essentially
split the minds of vision and wonder man
in two and restore them back to their
original selves and so what they end up
doing is basically alerting tony stark
james rhodes jumps in kind of gets into
the conflict which is sort of a big deal
for him because remember the last time
he was in a conflict like this it was
with thanos prior to the events of civil
war ii and he died but at the same time
of course tony stark is in need of this
treatment that'll basically separate him
from his own armor if that doesn't
happen then he will basically die here
and so the funny thing about all this is
that we're this massive fight right
between james rhodes and ultron which
goes exactly the way you would expect it
to where james rose is getting handled
quite readily basically
he's no iron man and the war machine
armor is cool but it's just not enough
to keep up with ultron while all this
stuff is happening tony stark's getting
his treatment he's being separated away
from his own armor and basically being
returned back to his normal self what
you end up getting here is arnold stark
who resurrects his parents who basically
creates new bodies and throws their
minds in it it just happens behind the
scenes and that's one of the cool things
here is that arnold is just kind of
removed but also there and it's a cool
circumstance to see it just kind of
strikes me is interesting right like i
don't know what it is about it but it
just sort of strikes me as intriguing
it's something that i just don't really
see all too often now of course the
procedure with tony stark is successful
of course tony stark goes back to his
normal self the problem with this is
that the friday ai along with the other
artificial intelligence components of
stark's whole process were basically
destroyed in order to keep ultron from
hacking into his systems or to keep
himself from being merged with his armor
now of course it proved to be
ineffective in the first place but what
this means is that with regards to all
the various iron man suits that he has
none of them can really work because
there's no ai there at the same time he
ends up having to go low-tech because if
he goes low-tech pimtron can't really
access it and so what he does is he
basically dawns one of the really really
old-school ironman armors an interesting
concept to sort of yank out of the
woodwork in addition to this there's a
few things that happen in really really
quick succession one of the first things
is that the forces the scientific forces
of tony stark show up with these
weaponized you know kind of cures for
lack of a better word and basically
separate these various henchmen who had
been merged into cybernetic components
from the cybernetic components
themselves restoring them back to them
back to their normal cells the other
part of this is tony stark starts
talking to hank pym and one of the
things he says is he's not a real person
that tony stark basically says he's a
simulation and the reason why is because
his physical body is dead right it's
gone the only way for him to really
return was to create an artificial body
for himself in the same way that arnold
stark had created artificial bodies for
howard and maria when that was done he
downloaded his consciousness into that
body now of course we talked about that
when we first picked up with tony stark
iron man as the pickup after the events
of civil war ii with the return of iron
man after he was killed by uh by carol
danvers during the civil war ii event
but the other part of this and one of
the other cool things that goes on is
howard and maria are watching this and
as far as we're concerned they really
are just real people right so you can
almost kind of see this as dan slot
seeming to kind of build up to like the
iron man equivalent of like the clone
conspiracy from spider-man or something
on those lines but it's it's cool here
because when he has this conversation
like when he says this he basically
tells hank pym on the count of three my
guys are gonna fire their machines at
you and when they do they're gonna
separate you and ultron you're gonna go
back to your normal self and ultron's
gonna go back to his normal self pemtron
will basically be a thing of the past
and it's cool because i was looking at
this and i was like okay finally
somebody's basically undoing pemtron
because the reality of this is that
ultron was a really cool villain and i
love stories like age of ultron i loved
how they were written and hank pym was
always somewhat intriguing if only for
no other reason than the fact that he
had like his multiple personalities and
he was always having a mental breakdown
or something along those lines and not
really seeing those two characters
operate and be out there in the form
that we're used to and instead just kind
of seeing this pim-tron concept which
has just basically been lingering for a
number of years would be kind of cool to
see it go away unfortunately dan slott
doesn't do that
he doesn't separate the characters
instead pimtron just basically
surrenders out of his desire to remain
in his current form and then in turn
he's basically you know handed over to
the avengers who have arrived on the
scene at the conclusion of the fight how
convenient
you know after finally figuring out
what's going on and realizing they were
sent to the sent to a location where
there was no major conflict but as a
result of that pymtron is essentially
locked away inside of a vibranium prison
of sorts that's created by black panther
and then essentially locked closed using
enchant enchantments of doctor strange
now what this means is it basically
allows dan slot to put pimtron on the
back burner there's room here for dan
slot to bring uh pymtron back but to
basically remove him and put him in a
position to where you as the reader you
know when i is the reader don't really
have to ask the question is he gonna
make a return it gives really dan slott
and the rest of marvel the ability to
just focus on other things what this
really comes down to is just tying up
loose plot threads and and really
nothing more and so so following this
conclusion this defeat of uh of pemtron
then things just kind of unfold things
just kind of go down from there you end
up having arno stark who basically
develops the the god buster armor of
tony stark from the escape but uses it
for his own ends and then really kind of
dawns himself you know as iron man 2020
and then of course this will basically
pick up in january but basically that's
kind of you know assuming this will this
will continue on i don't know why it
wouldn't i think that what you're going
to end up seeing is kind of like dual
iron man stories right so it's going to
be like the iron man equivalent of like
superman and action comics right you're
going to have iron man 2020 and you're
probably gonna have the iron man comics
i haven't read too much into the
solicitations i usually like to keep
myself surprised with what's going on
but i do like the idea the story was
awesome i love the idea of iron man's
ultron buster armor especially because
it didn't work
that he used ultron buster armor on an
ultron that was totally prepared for it
that was actually kind of cool right so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob corp if you guys want to
see my uncensored videos my versus
videos or my early access videos head
over to patreon.com comics explained and
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and i'll catch you guys
later
peace